歡迎收看
最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀
我是李肇華
我們都說要不要打腳呢
今天算是打下去了吧
盤中有下跌大約1000點
原因在昨天晚上
廢半指數就跌了5個百分點
為什麼
鬼故事又在傳了
說所謂的AI大廠們
他們的隱性負債高達3兆美元
又看到公債直率率飆上去
哎 只有代表大家如果舉債的話
這個利息啊是水漲船高
擔心未來又是一個泡沫的破裂
但好像這個鬼故事也有點熟悉
不是新的
好 所以費販帶大跌之後
今天台股有一個順勢拉回
可是也留下了一個下影線
中場是下跌了589點
那大家要問
反彈到這邊
其實回檔一下也是正常的
高低點落差也出現了2000點
現在局勢穩了嗎
我們常常講
呈先起後
腳打好了
就要可以重新再上
今天就是要來告訴您
非常有機會
醞釀重新再上
到底該如何布局
來歡迎今天的三位來賓
第一位是
K線之神竹家宏竹老師
竹老師之前
上禮拜就講了
應該是要打腳的
有很多技術面上的綜合原因
那今天就來問了
朱老師那腳打好了沒有
他說 ok 的只要打好
站上關鍵均線
他有一個更大的目標架
在後面等大家
而且今天要來跟大家講一個好消息了
好多的股票叫做打底完成
N字底一字底都有
今天會好好的舉例給您聽
尤其以族群性來說
被動元件完成底型的特別多
待會來了
第二位是我們的產業趨勢專家王健文王博
王博也要說公債值利率往上飆
油價往上飆
結果科技股就紛紛落馬了
因為很擔心他們的舉債成本越來越高
但是我們也可以看到
現在可以抗衡的就是漲價
今天公利元件
十一元件
這段時間相對抗跌也都發出了漲價函
這兩個族群好好來跟您解說
好戲在後頭以及SPEXX
前面在跌 現在開始升空囉
相關的大股東都沒有賣股票
台灣的低軌衛星供應鏈
是不是也要再來一波呢
第三位是我們的存股教父
骨瑜 骨瑜今天來要擴整一句話
就連軍開發所講的
光通訊缺到爆
骨瑜是研發工程師出身的
等下會告訴你研發在做什麼
為什麼光通訊很缺
以及一個東西叫做靈化音
等一下真的要好好來上課了
林華英概念沒有錯
到底他整個工藝鏈循環長怎樣
今天精挑細選其中的股票
因為要符合股語講的
真正業績有成長
精挑細選待會來聽喔
好首先有請朱老師
說實話上禮拜喔
我們都覺得
可能沒有什麼第二隻腳了吧
但看來這兩天
確實往下打
打好了沒
特別你講到
如果打好就是多頭形態重新啟攻
就要教我們喔
好多打底的N字底
頭先底 一字底
都很適合底部買
我們來看一下
因為昨天
我們看一下我們的指數
因為昨天有一些比較
力空的消息
油價漲啊
通紅一律 公代直律 綠標啊
還有公代直律 綠標
所以今天早上大家看到
美股就嚇一跳
飛半天5%
就想完蛋了完蛋了
那結果今天一開盤
真是一開盤就殺下去
但是如果被嚇到股票一賣
哇 又賣到地板了
好 我們大概比較關心的
還是我們的大盤
我們大盤上次來的時候
還沿著武軍一直反彈
對 就覺得不搭轎了
很強 逼轉了
但是這種強力反彈
它只是告訴我們
這個形態趨勢要改變
不然都是這種弱弱的反彈
它不會這麼強
所以這麼強的反彈
就告訴我們後面是有行情的
我們可以去期待了
所以上禮拜來的時候
也因為反彈在高點 量也縮
所以看起來就沒力
每天早跟100多點 100多點
也現在我們來講
哇 這個等於沒漲 對不對
好 那昨天就確認了
不是今天 昨天就跌破五軍了
所以昨天就是反彈結束
這叫反彈結束
如果你強反的人 昨天就可以走了
強反 而且強反彈的人
哇 這強反彈強很多的
強好幾千點
6千點
對 搶到6千點
那今天只是
昨天回檔的今天的蓄碟
再加上今天早上又是這個
美股不好嘛
所以被這個
所以這裡有個跳空的缺口
好 那我們來看一下
如果這個回來
我們在上載也講
回來有幾個重要的關鍵
去看一下
最好當然是
因為季線在上面
而且我們的軍線都向上
最好是這個季線能夠把它撐住
但今天因為開盤跌幅太大
這個市場反應已經
已經拉了下影線了
但這個還不太夠
這個下影 因為我們還有一個缺口
所以明天最重要其實是月線
好不容易站上月線
而且月線也拉上來
如果月線明後天表現
都有支撐的話
也就是說跌下去拉上來
或者甚至於還留了紅K的話
那這就是一個支撐的現象
那有了支撐 有了變盤線
我們就看什麼時候戰上武軍
如果他能夠戰上武軍
第二隻腳就完成
而且這個第二隻腳完成
連趨勢也完成
不是只有底底高打底
因為他這已經過了
我們上禮拜講這邊有頭頭高了
對不對
所以現在你一上去
這就叫底底高
上次有特別提到打腳才好
因為多頭形態確認完成
對 整個我們的
好不容易把空又轉成多
當然這個多我們也不要說太過於期望
因為我們這裡還有壓
這裡還有一個歷史高點
但至少它不會離歷史高點越來越遠
它現在又接近了
所以不管是有壓沒壓
我能夠把多頭趨勢做出來的話
即使短時間不過
它也會在這邊做整理
因為這是已經是一個多頭趨勢
是
好 那我們就看如果
當然最理想的大家期望的就是
上午均嬰就過了
就變成又V上去
那這個就變N字底了
N字底
這就是N字底
如果是這樣走的話
N字底就是這個到這裡的漲幅
從最低點
因為明天可能還會有低點
從最低點加上去
那這就有機會看到武漢去了
是
但是到5萬之前
還有一個主力
就是我們的歷史高點
畢竟這還是一個壓
如果這個主力
天花板給它頂破的話
那到5萬根本就是沒有問題
大家就可以想
它一定到5萬的機率
非常高了
這是我們的大盤
那另外一個
如果跌破月線
因為有提到
如果這個腳跌太深也不行
對 如果美股再繼續跌
或者影響大
或者另外的利空
那如果跌下來
我們上次講過
這個是不太容易再破了
因為這個地方的支撐非常多
也不能破
也就是說下來
這裡有跳躬缺口
這裡有個大量紅K
所以大概也不會差多少
是
那這個兩隻腳只要在這個
第二隻腳只要在1分之1的上面
它都符合N字底的條件
都是很好
那我們就密切的注意一下明後天
好不好
最好就是這樣了
不要再弱
再弱又麻煩了對不對
最近大家比較遇悶的就是台積電
奇怪了 這個台積電怎麼會
而且很長時間
在那邊大家討論度非常高
要三千 要破三千
可是一下怎麼搞了
一兩個月都不動
實際上因為台積電站的權力太大了
指數要修正
你台積電又大漲
那指數就沒辦法修正了
那這樣子會造成一種誤解
以為我們的大盤會一直漲
所以基本上我認為
台積電是留一個空間
從哪個地方可以看
因為台積電上市的地點
是不是在這
對
對不對
所以他就留一個空間
在這個地方
那歷史高點
他暫時先不要破
所以他在這裡做一些整理
那現在在兩個的區中
所以他大概在這邊整理整理
等到需要他的時候
就是要從5萬的時候
從歷史高點的時候
他就來了
所以這個報證是股票的這個投資人
未來是有希望
可是當下也需要有一點耐心
沒有關係
反正我講我們的大盤要衝出去
一定是要靠台積電
台積電是少不了的
只是短時間 別的在表現
那另外還有一個原因
其實我們這次大盤
各位都知道
好多股票不管是國居
不管是回來都很深
他沒有 它沒有跌二分之一
他就是一個稱盤要繳
所以基本上即使你覺得他很弱
他也沒有讓你大配
所以就稍微的抱一抱
未來還是會過這個253
還是會過的
好 那我們剛才就跟大家講說
這一次在底部
大盤再回來做第二支繳
很多的股票就在做底
那這個底裡面有3個很重要的形態
而且現在有很多的股票都這個選
第一個我們就講叫投間N字底的反轉
我們先講第一個底叫N字底
也是勝率最高的對不對
N字底我就講右邊嘛
我們看這邊
強力的反彈
然後做第二支角
第二支角剛好1.2的上面
它並沒有跌得很深
所以我們的大盤
只要不要跌破月線就這個位置
大盤目前就可能形成N字底
這個月線大概在這裡嘛
所以他只要越線支撐
他就會形成N字體
N字體目標價我們剛剛講這一段
從這個低門加這一段
好 目標價在這裡喔
那現在大盤歸大盤嘛
因為有人可能會去做
當然大部分人還是做股票
所以我們這些股票
現在有的已經是N字體
有的是N字體的第二支角
已經出來了
所以你就可以準備
準備
要過高才確認嘛
我們就等他過高
因為他有第二隻腳
我就知道這個位置
這個位置就很明確了
好 那我們來看一下
這個已經確認了
這個都已經創新高了
對 所以他確認了
那大家一定會
這隻骨票大家一定會覺得
這不像剛才講的嘛 對不對
不是 這隻骨票
因為他創新高的搭局
哪有什麼地
這也是N值底
N值底的另一種型態的表現
各位看這個是不是連續集長
掌庭 掌庭 掌庭
所以這個叫做強力反彈
可是這你有五六天都沒有長
橫盤
所以這叫橫盤
然後這個呢
又上工了
你看像不像N字
這個N字沒有回來
就很強勢是不是
那更強啊
我們剛剛講回來
二分之一嘛
是不是回來這裡
它根本沒回來
它沒有回來
所以如果你看到一支股票
反彈 橫盤突破
這個地方就是N字底的
這個旗長
而且很強
很強
好 果然很強
因為這兩天
今天當然不好 其實他也沒疊
他就在那邊休息
對 這個是當然籌碼也不錯
外資投信都在買
那這一支就像我剛剛講
我們就等他 因為他有這個了
他都已經快到錢高的位置
那昨天那是回來了
那今天要過了
也就是說如果明天過
他是不是這樣 他是不是就這樣
他就恩知鼎嘛
OK 所以這個因為在這裡
因為他有壓了
所以他在這邊稍微整理一下
他只要一過
他也是一個標準的恩智迪
那這一千張大戶
這個表現就更積極了
至少我們也知道
籌碼上可能不需要太過於擔心
沒錯 有人照顧
有大人在裡面
那第二個叫頭肩底
頭肩底 我剛剛有講
右邊是恩智迪
這個是恩智迪
可是他左邊有一個
轉折的地點
這邊 對
那這個低點跟這個低點是相對的
差不多的 差不多對應的
也都在二分之一上
那這個邊就因為有了左肩
所以這個就變右肩
那一樣兩個高點突破
他的目標價就加一倍
好 目標價在這個位置喔
可是目前也很多這種股票
我也也也
而且都很好的
光鞋 台新科
這些現在都是投奸的
好 我們來看一下廣運
機器人概念廣運
那這裡是不是有個低點
那這裡有個紅K上來
所以這裡有個左肩
然後就左邊那個
下去又上來
這個上尾線嘛
那我們現在再畫一條
還差一步喔
昨天下來今天到這
看那個圖就知道了
對 長一樣
還差一根
可是說好他今天爆亮
可是鎖不住
因為今天有與數科技掛牌
有帶動機器人
那這樣子會不會不好
不會啊
因為頭肩底左邊的高點是壓力
所以他今天 壓力壓了
對 他今天反應一下嘛
那如果他在稍微的整理幾天
也是一樣 都把它當作頭肩底
那你就自己大概可以去算一下
他的目標價 短線
那如果他上來就多頭了
那你就後面再繼續做
這就是頭肩底的型態
再來一個就是一字底
其實一字底就是底部打的
時間比較久
但是因為最近大盤都是微星反轉
所以我們看到的股票
也都微星反轉
比較多啦 N字底啊 頭肩底
所以在底下還躺那麼久的股票
就不多了 就不多
可是還是有
我們還是找到
尤其昨天好像韓玉谷
透明幫他噴
還有一些散裝都漲停板
今天也有散裝 漲停
好 那這一支我們就可以
所謂的這個一字底就是
十軍 五軍 二十軍都擺在一起
全部都擺在這一塊
全部都在這
然後是不是要有一根大量衝出來
這一衝出來
這些軍線全部都上來了
所以這個就是標準的
這個一字底或者軍線糾結的突破
那其實這個我們還可以稍微的解釋一下
只是它不是很明顯
為什麼 這也是一個反彈
然後這也是一個盤子
這也是N字底
只是因為他 我講不要
為什麼不把他當做一字底
因為這個太短了
你如果讓一字底
那這一根就到了 就到架了
就已經到了
那怎麼會跑那麼快
原來這邊還有一個均線糾結
所以我剛剛有講過
同一個地方
你如果看這個 那就N字底
如果你看這一塊
均線都糾在這裡
那這個叫均線糾結的突破
那現在就拉回座嘛 對不對
他已經形態也完成了
均線也完成了
這個都已經完成
我們把它拉回來去追蹤就好了
所以在現在很多的股票
被動元件 前一陣子我剛剛講
大家都跌很多
尤其我們的國劇對不對
大家去注意一下
這些好的股票
如果有符合 比如說這頭尖底
何生堂前一陣子很會漲的
對
這個是N字底
那這些幾乎都已經可以了嘛
回後等上漲
我回來等他上漲
那馬上漲就更好了
好
對 這也是等上漲
所以這樣子就意識
他至少抵不出來了
大家都可以去追溶一下
你看看新商店是不是一樣
他錢高不在
這裡有個錢高
他現在上來
現在在做第二隻腳
那一樣嘛
他只要一衝出去
N字底要過這個頭嘛
所以如果明後天過
它就會變成一個字
就會符合N字底
對 符合N字底
這裡是投信
投信買了
對 投信介入了
投信本來就還滿喜歡它
但這一波下來沒辦法
它也跌了不少了
它的業績是成長滿多
可是它這樣子上面的空間
就會流很大
對不對
那這個也是很標準
反彈
現在回答也是等這個
滑星科
你看這個畫著N字底
如果你把這個加進來
這裡有一個嘛
你把這個加進來
它就變投間底
那如果是投間底或者是N字底
都要把這個高點給突破
對 很多
那大家都可以去看
因為這些股票才剛剛打底
所以上面的空間很難倒
好 非常謝謝朱老師
好 朱老師要特別提醒我們
打第二隻腳
不是希望什麼台股漲不動了
要回檔
而是回檔後
整個形態就會完成一個多頭
如果N字底打好的話
我們把目標架是可以往上等幅加上去的
這樣後面海闊天空
尤其是現在如果看到個股的部分
好多喔
頭肩底也好
一字底也好
N字底也好
都即將成形了
這反而是大家在選股上面
以技術形態有相當多的選擇
輔助於法人籌碼的話
會更有把握
好 廣告回來
王博要上場了
王博也要說
到底昨晚會辦在疊什麼
這樣的傳聞會時不時出來干擾台股
可是我們心中要有定件
等一下會告訴你
向公立元件 實營元件
明明就是已經是在漲價的路上
而且下半年有可能越漲越多
股票市場很奇妙
我們常常想說
這樣一直談不會打腳
可是偏偏就會出現一些奇怪的事
昨天會辦大疊
疊什麼
就在跌說科技巨頭這樣舉債
看到美國的公債直率率跑上去
就利率環境變得很貴
他們的舉債可能會破掉
就因為這句話
所以科技股大跌
但是王博就要來澄清了
不是啊
我們的公率元件 實際元件
還有很多的元件
其實都在漲下嘛
對 那又回檔了
在季線附近應該是可以減便宜的
再來 SbSx
夢想升空了
最近指紋
我們的低軌衛星這一波也跌很慘
也要跟著升空
其實這波很多股票跌很慘
但是有的股票
彈身上來速度很快
所以大家想說
之前那個在低點不敢買
漲了七千點上來
現在在想說
正想要開始大展生成的時候
突然覺得怎麼樣
好日子是不是要結束
不過我個人認為
好日子
如果你在低點沒有買的話
回測季線
你可以把它當成新的起點
搞不好好的日子才剛好開始
那當然
其實昨天影響最大
就是這個全球債市
因為那個美債長天期的
突然之間飆上去
當然鬼故事是一直的重複
那包含像所謂的十年債的
那個長債的那個直率
衝上那個所謂四點七五
三十年的那個美債直率
突破百分之五點三
這個其實都已經到歷史高點
所以你到歷史高點的時候
突然之間又有所謂的鬼故事
大家的衝擊更大
為什麼 因為剛才趙有提到
如果我每債
公債都能夠來到10年期4.75%
然後30年期的公債值
利率能夠5.3%
那其他
那麼多的AI對不對 要發債
那就變成說
那你接下來你要用什麼樣的條件
所以大家才在想說
那個隱形負債
那個來到三兆美元會不會爆
說真的
平常心講 你現在敢發債
然後所謂的相關條件開出來的時候
人家還要的 基本上都是大的
你大了 其實你要他倒
其實沒有那麼容易
不過我的看法是這樣
我的看法是就是說
因為目前的確
對大家來講
還是有個心裡面的因素在
為什麼 因為其實包含像通膨胃結
然後大家很擔心 擔心說
FED是不是又要升息
可是我看那個滑雪
滑雪好像不大想升息
他畢竟還是川普
對川普甚至想要降息
等一下我們來討論
另外就是說
現在大家擔心那個財政赤字
因為你那個財政赤字一直往上的話
那你就必須要發更多的債
就是我們剛才提到說
那資金排擠的狀況
會不會越來越嚴重
甚至人家會去擔心
擔心說
你美國政府會不會倒
說真的是疑慮
美國政府應該是不會倒了
但是問題是
這個大魔王
這個大魔王大家就會很緊張
很緊張說
那如果你發那麼多債
然後利率越來越高的話
你的債息是不是要付出更多
付出來了
對 付出來了
另外就是我們剛才提到的說
資金如果排擠的話
那我企業如果要再
要更多的錢
勢必有的條件要再往上提升
因為其實就是投資人
要求的報酬會更多
那這個相關的情況出來之後
那你就看到昨天美國股市
你知道特別是廢半
好不容易這樣爬牙 爬到極限
又掉下
我的看法是 我認為
因為都已經到達歷史高點附近
其實是有機會反轉的
有機會反轉
那主要的幾個理由
不如像 川普有沒有可能又踏口
很常嘛 川普常常踏口
因為我們也沒有辦法預測他
但是如果川普又踏口的話
那個油價是不是又會掉下來
不過他現在籌碼越來越少了
因為畢竟其中選舉了
他籌碼越來越少 不會啊
他說那個核母汁是他的
沒理他
看到的時候認住了什麼時候
何母之海峽是他的
所以我們來看一下我們機會
又taco 如果taco的話
其實油價下來
大家對那個通膨的疑慮又會降
另外就是說
我們還是根據所謂
FED watch的那個相關的內容
其實現在剩下三次
就是9月 10月 12月
那我們看到其實9月 10月
只要沒有升息
基本上今年應該不會升息
因為12月那次
我看華許要脫
也會把他拖過去
升息的機率都低於百分之五十
所以這個可能怎麼可能
心裡面的影響程度很大
那聯準會是不是有實際的作為
目前看起來
他可能還是維持利率不變
至於所謂的那個股市
其實除了那個費辦
從低點慢慢爬上來
然後到季線附近震盪
其實標普是創高的
納斯達克要挑戰前高
所以基本上股市的型態是往上
所以我比較正面
因為我看標普跟納斯達克
如果還是維持多頭的話
多頭其實回檔修正
應該是站在買方
所以這個我們在操作的過程當中
可能可能會參考那個朱老師
那提醒大家是不是
鯰谷壓回季線
是大家的好機會
那美債的問題
如果能夠向我們提到的
就是說一一的破解
然後甚至那個
那個所謂的直立率
所謂長債直立率
你能夠從高點往下修正的話
那當然我們就來看臺灣
重啟公事
那臺灣其實很重要一點就是籌碼
那當然大家在討論那個所謂的
臺子期的結算
結算完之後呢
其實我覺得它的那個
空單的進空部位有稍微減1萬
9萬跑回8萬
但是還是很多
但是我覺得應該會慢慢的減少
為什麼 那個
他在這邊進空部位那麼高
沒有沒有沒有用
為什麼 因為如果美國股市在上去的話
其實對他來講
他不如把那個進空部位
慢慢的再往下縮減
以前三四萬就了不起
現在都八萬九萬
有很多套利啦
之類的
這個可能要考慮
套利都混在一起
那至於啦
至於大家會看那個
散戶的多空筆
今天看起來好像又跳進去了
大家都好勇敢
可是我覺得會贏
為什麼我覺得會贏
因為其實今天如果你看那個
台子旗跟台股的話
早上是殺下來之後
馬上往上啦
其實早上殺下來馬上往上拉
其實那個絕對不是一般散戶
一定是什麼 一定是有實力
有實力的大戶他才會做
殺下來之後往上拉
因為基本上 基本上今天的下影線
加權指數現在大概410點
所以基本上 基本上
下來之後往上拉這一段
應該是有實力的大戶
然後可能有一些什麼
有一些散戶慢慢的進去
其實我覺得
我覺得這一筆單贏的金率很高
那我覺得啦
如果到季線這個階段
我們到底要怎麼做
我覺得我可能還是會回來看漲價概念
是
因為其實漲價概念股很多
這波很強的
不像所謂的臺光電
不像所謂的星星
台一樣
對
其實
我說真的
如果說你看到這些漲價概念股
不像南亞這樣子往上帶的話
其實其他的漲價概念股
你就要先做功課
那當然這個是一發半導體
一發半導體
最新的那個通知客戶
這個好像說要跟你拖集
八月二十三號要漲價
要漲價 先告訴你
先告訴你
那當然之前包含像英飛靈
然後一些所謂的得宜
這些也跟你講要漲價
所以這個也不意外
那我會怎麼看
我會看說
那我要先緊盯大廠的漲價趨勢
如果趨勢是往上
他不是往下
那代表什麼
代表其實我們這些
臺灣的相關廠商
他可能怎麼可能營收
上來 獲利也會上來
這個很重要
那另外就是說
其實很多股票是慢慢的在震盪走高
所以你就分批超底 區間操作
那這是我幫大家整理出來
大家也可以怎麼樣 舉一反三
把自己喜歡
然後愛操作的股票加進去
他自己加進去是不是
對對對 自己加進去
不是要分是十音元件跟功率元件
對 他自己加
但是你要加對
你不能說十音元件
然後加去功率元件
你要自己加對不對
這有時候就是說
有時候我們是把指標股列出來
主要廠商應該都在啦
對對對
那我們把主要的廠商
列出來之後
你也可以看
因為有的股票可能
領頭羊上來之後
其他的地點賣美會上來
現在看起來
投信也有在公立元件略為著墨
但是大戶倒是
兩個族群都有在賣
特別啦
特別我是覺得滿特別的是
千張大戶在經濟跟西華是
指標信兩大廠 不領不棄
而且他是很持續的那個增加
然後包含像所謂公立元件
其實包含像帽達 富鼎
富鼎今天開高
然後殺下來
感覺上好像今天開高
去反應漲價
但是可能被大盤部門
短線的那個沖下來
我覺得其實大家都可以留意
就是有些股票
如果說像法輪在買
然後大戶在買
這些股票你就可以留意
那我們先來看經濟
其實之前經濟這一波
我也是看達人秀 幸福
幸福哥說他是一個指揮家
對不對 我也是
11年間是個指揮家
這一波其實以前經濟給大家的看法是很牛
很不好做的股票
那我也是看大家就我看信不講
後來漲一大段
那現在就是說
找機會來幫大家追蹤一下
所以現在你要送暖了 因為回檔了嗎
其實回檔幅度也不深
其實因為大家現在看你知道嗎
你知道那個光通訊 高速傳輸
其實現在不管是800G 1.6T
速度是越來越快
所以其實信不有提醒大家
那個所謂高階的那個震盪器的那個
重要性就提高了
甚至我看有一些媒體的報導說
2027年是什麼
就是明年嘛 就是高評元年
明年很快就到了
對 明年很快 高評元年
所以這些客戶你就要注意嘛
上半年EPS的2.96 7月字節0.86
很漂亮 主要客戶就高通
聯發科 博通 賣威爾
所以我覺得大家也可以留意
那當然其實漲價函他之前就發了
然後另外就是高階評立元件供需吃景
交貨其他藏到六州
這就是說 反正我現在
交貨群拉長了 代表什麼
大家搶著要擔的狀況下
那個漲價他也只能接受
所以我覺得這兩股票
經濟你把它當成領頭羊
我覺得有機會
那另外如果是冒達
那這種股票其實漲了一段之後
其實也壓回
而且這一波其實沒有明顯的上漲
他沒有談
對 但是問題來了
大戶的持股是增加的
是 對 所以我認為
我認為他主要客戶是台達店
廣達 微創華碩對不對
然後社會AI推升高壓
搭公立元件的需求
我覺得這種股票你要留意
主要是算一字底嗎
動都不動
快 差不多了
差不多
越線已經下來了
越線已經靠起來
所以這類型的股票還沒有表態的
就是我們提到說
那個季線
如果大盤的季線當作基準起點的話
這些股票你要留意
當然除了所謂漲價的概念股之外
其實這個有點送暖了
就是說
Spaces有那麼不好嗎
然後低軌衛星概念股
有那麼不好嗎 其實不會
那當然
如果我們看Spaces的大股東的話
包含像谷歌 包含像所謂輝達
包含像油國 油國的基金
包含像傅達 雞腳放
其實你可以發覺說
他們也沒有那個
他們也是不離不棄
或是你投資馬斯克
真的要有長期抗戰的準備
他們也沒有說
我那個上來之後就變現
目前看起來是沒有
那這一組股票
其實我們之前幫大家追蹤過
那我會怎麼做
我會當然要追蹤法人大戶
所以這個大家還是要做功課
另外就是緊盯獲利分批超底
那我們期待什麼
期待說他營收上來 獲利也上來
所以我幫大家找兩檔股票
一檔股票是
升達科 一檔股票是升碼
你要雙升是不是
兩個都要上升
為什麼要找
是因為我看他們上半年的EPS
是超過去年全年
獲利進度非常好
對 找好股票 找獲利的好股票
那當然最純的低軌衛星概念股
當然就是升達科的
而且前期月營收年增百分之七十
Spaces 灣位不是他的主要客戶
然後他最近一個動作是收購巨頻科技
那個消息出來之後
股票直接往上跳
那當然他收購巨頻科技
主要是要搶進AI高速傳輸市場
所以我覺得
我覺得他除了低軌衛星這一塊
如果說也能夠在AI這一塊
再加把勁的話
這檔股票其實也不動很久了
所以沉默很久搞不好
這檔股票有機會就這樣上來
那另外一檔股票是3305的深茂
好 只要跟息相關的都有做
主要的客戶是SpecS
蘋果要發新機了
美光 美光也是很熱
那個麥克風
大麥空 空美光又被剋
產能滿載 這是他上次講的
然後另外就是說他
專利的低溫習高
就是習高部分
如果說你在太空的話
他把它稱之為太空最強的膠水
對 就是在於那個相關的那個
漢漢街部分
那另外他要積極開發高階散熱材料
那我覺得啦
因為我剛才看一下包含像齊宏
包含像深帽
這個都跟所謂的那個什麼散熱有關的
這兩檔股票都是千張大戶
在增加持股
所以如果說騎龍上去
那太空相關的商機上來的話
我覺得生貿大家可以留意
其實生貿就散落在個體裁
對不對 散熱 太空
他都有
因為他這個習高
算是是戰略蠻高的
我覺得業績今年是大成長
上半年一批
就已經超過去年權
非常謝謝王伯
謝謝趙華
王伯也提醒
像諸如大家的負債往上升
供在直立路往上跑
這樣的壓力 這樣的說法
會持續的反反覆覆的出現
但是要記得一件事情
川普 華許其實並不希望
進入到升息循環
會想盡辦法把銅鵬給克制下來
所以這樣子的話
不如來看一下一些會漲價
而且發出漲價函的例如公立元件
函十一元件
都已經在這波股災上面修認下來了
修認下來了
現在會不會是一個甜甜的買點
以及SpaceX都已經回暖了
我們的低軌衛星概念股
是不是也應該反攻一波
廣告回來 骨瑜要上場囉
以前是資深研發主管的他
今天要來好好幫我們上課了
大家都說靈化陰 缺料
這個光通訊的缺口很大
骨瑜有研究 等一下告訴你
相關的股票裡面
搭配他已經看到基本面
確實成長的優哪些
好 我們知道骨瑜研究存股研究ETF
但是我剛剛忍不住問他說
你在研發的時候都在做什麼
所以他今天要來好好發揮這個研發的精神
告訴大家
當我們聽到三五足 聽到林華英
有缺口有缺料
到底台灣有哪些廠商是真的受惠
而且已經反映在營收上面了
這就要來問你了
因為現在進入到這個
你會覺得這本夢筆的東西
這跟你這個價值存股離太遠了吧
可是跟你以前說做研發又有關係
所以今天來好好講
所謂的光通訊缺到爆
以及有哪些股票是真的在這個領域
業績又好的
OK
那事實上我們有幾件事情要稍微澄清一下
澄清什麼
首先第一件事情的話
他真的在缺貨
這第一件事情
第二件事情的話
有一些夢做久了會變成真的
美夢成真
做研發就是這個樣子嘛
對不對
每天都在做夢
但是夢久了
努力的去做
總有成真的一天嘛
對不對 這個就是做研發的人
一定要樂觀的原因
那你為什麼不繼續在這個光電業
繼續做研發
因為趙華邀請我來上節目
所以呢 我們就一然而然的決定
來這裡重新做一個新的夢
對嘛 你看美夢成真
對 沒有錯
那我們今天先來看一下
那最近聯軍這邊的話
開了一場法說會
裡面所有的內容都不重要
都不重要
最重要的就只有一個字
什麼字
缺
當這個缺的字出現之後
背後是有一些原因的
首先的話是揮達新的一代的
AI伺服器的主機
然後這一次的話
他會連同新的光通訊元件
整合在一起之後做出貨的一個動作
但是這裡面有一個重點
你今天裡面的光通訊元件
要能夠順利的出貨
他的關鍵材料必須要夠才行
那這個關鍵材料的話就是這個
零化音的這個基板
所以今天誰能夠供應大量的靈化因的基板
誰就能夠在這一波出貨的浪潮當中的話
賺得盆滿駁滿
那我們看到他漲價的原因之後
我們先開始來看
到底發生了什麼故事
因為從年初開始
他就已經開始在漲價了
年初靈化因就在漲價了
就已經開始在漲價了
而且已經有預估說
今年的第四季將會在大漲一成以上
看到這邊好像還沒有什麼
但是更重要的來了
現在開始傳出國際的大廠
已經在跟上游簽訂長約顧料
在公益商的關係裡面的話
我要不要跟你簽約
除了我供給你的料夠不夠多之外
另外一個的話
更重要的是我要綁定你的價格
我預期未來這個價格
還會繼續再往上走
所以我必須在這個時間點
我先用長約把價格先綁起來
讓你之後的話
就算漲價了
我也不會受到太多的傷害
今年有一個產業
他也是綁了長約
記憶體
所以記憶體
後來長成什麼樣子
各位都知道了
對不對
所以我會跟觀眾朋友講
如果記憶體的這一波
缺貨漲價
所長約的這一段
你沒有把握到的話
你現在又有個機會來了
看起來菱花鷹的話
現在正在複製當初基於體
上漲的那一段路徑
所以我們來看一下
我們幫各位做一些教育訓練
國中的夢魘又來了
講完不要這麼說
國中要上元素週期表
對 沒有錯
為什麼會把元素週期表拿出來呢
因為我們這個靈化音
它是一種三五組的元件
可是有時候講三五組
大家都聽不太懂
什麼叫做三五組
而且我一直有個疑問
深化家 碳化系
靈化鷹啦
不是大家都會一直在講這些嗎
為什麼現在確實是靈化鷹
為什麼嗎
因為啊
他需要的是你不同的族群
他去做搭配之後的話呢
他會產生不同的一個特性
他跟呢這個所謂的細基板不太一樣
我們今天在講半導體產業
其實講的就是
細晶圓細晶片的一個產業
可是這個
有一個嚴重的缺點
什麼缺點
你針對那些高速高頻的
還有發光的領域上面來講
細是沒有辦法去做這一塊的
但是我們今天在
3跟5的這個組裡面
它有個非常有趣的特性
它可以混搭
混搭
對
比如說GA跟N
這邊組合在一起的話
它就變成是一個
快充跟基地台的一個高效的一個充電器
叫做彈化加
彈化加
那還有另外一個的話
比如說你的GA跟AS這邊
去做結合的話
大家都熟悉了
手機的功率放大氣
生化加
對 那現在的話
我們的特點就來自於說
我的IN
跟我的PE去做結合之後的話
他竟然可以變成
光通訊雷射的重要元件
所以呢
商務組他有趣的地方就在這邊
好 那在我們瞭解他相關的
一個特性之後的話
接下來我要來破解各位
在產業上面的一個迷思
那我這邊的話
幫各位整理的一張表格
我幫你從善終下的關係
全部整理在一起
大家聽到的名詞要理解
他們其實是不一樣
但是同一個領域
還有用途
他最終的用途的話
就是要成為CPU
就是要成為共同瘋狂光學的這個模組
但是我們在之前
聽到這個所謂的細光紙的這一塊的話
指的是說
我今天的細晶片
把我的訊號送出來之後
我為什麼把它變成光送出去
所以這邊的話
需要的是一個光直整合計數
所以這邊的話稱為細光直
可是你今天光出來之後
你要怎麼去跟外面溝通
那這個部分的話
叫做光電的整合架構
這邊就是我們比較常聽到的
所謂的cpo的元件
但是現在的問題就來了
我現在cpo準備要出貨了
結果賀蘭發現
哎呦 靈化因供應的量的話
好像會因為我的出貨
需要大幅度的一個提高
那過去的話
可能他的用途是比較受限的
所以大家的產能就開得比較小
那現在突然需求爆亮了
廠商的話
他可能就第一個先抬高價格
第二的話準備去擴張他相關的一個產能
所以我們今天只要聽到這個所謂
零化音 細光紙 CPO
其實他講的都是同一件事情
如何讓我們晶片裡面的這些訊號
能夠用最短的路徑
把它給送出去
所以我這邊用一個非常簡單的圖
來幫各位做一個解釋
就是說我今天不成熟的CPU
我的訊號從這裡出來
我要經過很長的一段路徑
我才能夠把它給送出去
可是我真正終極完成版的CPU的話
它就是長成這個樣子
這個路徑一看當然就知道
我們都要往這個方向
對不對 縮短傳出距離
和它的耗損一定要減低
可是誰能做到
這就是我們從外行
我們不知道的事情
對 沒有錯
所以我這邊就幫各位
整理了一張攻略表
這張是你覺得能做到的嗎
這邊的話是他們宣稱可以做到的
但是我們在裡面有發現幾家廠商
他已經真的去默默的做了一些相關的動作
那我們今天的話把這個表整理出來之後
你要幫我看一個關鍵字
哪個關鍵字哪個關鍵字
關鍵字是英文喔
是英文嗎
對對對
我再幫各位把這個整理在這邊
幫我看一下
金屬有機物化學氣象成績
M-O-CVD
M-O-CVD我們是聽過啦
但不管聽過多少次
都覺得好抽象
對 很抽象
但是我跟你說
沒有關係
你一定要幫我記住一件事情
這個東西呢
如果要擴產第一件事情
它非常沒有辦法
從原有的機台裡面
去擴增它的一個產能
這是很困難的
他必須增加他的機台的設備
他才能夠去做擴產的一個動作
一般來講
如果我的需求不大
我是不太會願意去買這個設備的
因為很貴
而且這個設備來講的話
他從Tunin到最後能夠量產
需要花一定的一個時間
所以我們在看相關公司的法收費資料
我們發現有兩家公司
他真的花錢去買了MOCVD
所以我們今天在看
公司到底有沒有真的要動作
其實就是看他
MOCVD這個設備有沒有去做買進
而我們在看這些相關廠商的話
有兩家公司
他真的充電去買了
一家的話叫做連亞
連亞
一家的話叫做全新
很符合檯面上
大家第一個想到的
對 沒有錯
所以我也把它放到最上面
我也跟各位講說
為什麼我們一定要關注這兩家公司
因為下面這邊到底
他有多少的受惠我不確定
但是我非常的確定
聯亞跟全新這兩家公司
已經投入了資本支出
去跟他的廠商去購買的
MOCVD這樣子的設備
所以他後面的一個擴產計畫
應該是有所本的
累積相關供應鏈
先來看聯亞
對 那聯亞的部分
其實我們看他這個ROE的趨勢
確實往上看
我們就可以跟
我們的觀眾朋友講一件事情
這間公司的轉型已經完成了
已經完成了
對 因為你前面一旦在虧損的話
代表公司在做體質的一個轉換
那後面的上升的話
代表我前面的轉換
調整已經開始結束
而且開始讓獲利的趨勢
往上來做一個提升
所以你看
他的整個毛利率的部分的話
有沒有呈現一個所謂的三綠三針
他很明顯
對 這三綠三針非常的明顯
而且更重要的是
什麼
你在看明雅這間公司的時候
有一個重點
一定要去看
是
營收的備註
對 我們這
備註在哪裡
這邊這邊
你千萬不要只看它什麼年增率
月增率
是
我們以前有跟觀眾朋友講過
如果一間公司的營收賺太多的時候
對
它會去揭露說它為什麼賺錢
為什麼你賺這麼多
你錢哪裡來的
它7月的時候就備註
數據中心的產品出貨量
叫同期大幅度增加
有點籠統 這裡有點籠統
它這個的話指的就是光通訊
元件的供應量大幅度的增加
所以我們就看到的話
它長短期營收的話
出現跳增的一個現象
所以這代表說
我今天的擴產有所本
而且我的營收的增加也有所本
所以我們也看到說
當我們開始聽到
伺服器開始出貨之後的話
它的股價也出現了一波
非常明顯的一個彈身
而且它這個反彈是很強勁的
3305嘛 已經快要逼近前高的一個泛探
對 沒有錯 而且更重要的是
他的法說會裡面
他講了非常多的一些
成長率相關的一個消息
所以法人在參加完他的法說會之後
直接提出一個新的預估值
他預估他今年大家可以賺兩個股本
可是明年的話
根據他mocbt的產能
以及他的一個成長性
提出來的相關的數字
幫他重新做了一個驗算
他認為他明年有機會可以賺到四個股本
也就是說我今年看到的貨力已經是爆增了
可是我明年有可能比現在再多賺
一倍的一個貨力
這是很重要的
因為今年台股的上市貴企業的貨力成長度
非常非常高
但到明年平均的成長率就沒那麼高了
可是光通訊顯然明年會比今年還高
但是以你價值投資來說
他還是很
PE還是很高啊
PE很高的話
看你是用哪個PE去算囉
本益成長比嗎
就是說我們PE的話呢
比較保守的話
當然是用今年的這個數字
這太高了
可是你如果對於明年的數字上面
來看的話
你可能就是用這個39.2
下去算了
還是很高
對不對
那可是
有時候這種高速成長股
就是這個樣子
因為可能還有一些成長性的因子
是你們有考慮進去的
那考慮進去之後
那到底貴不貴的話
這個就要留給投資人
他自己去詳細的去做相關的一個評估
那另外一家公司的話
則是全新
那全新這間公司的話
基本上他跟去年相比的話
他也是呈現一個三綠三生的一個現象
而且更重要的是法人的話
逐月去調升
他EPS獲利的一個預期
所以你看
他之前人家預估他在賺3塊8
可是這樣子一路跑上來之後的話
今年到年底預估他可以賺到5塊
可是到明年的話
他有機會可以賺到9塊的一個程度
那這個部分也是隨著他法說相關的資料的一個法部
然後逐月的去做一個提升
所以我們在全新的法說位裡面是沒有聽到
他講到非常明確的一個數字
所以人家零是快3000
他現在是400
他如果願意把數字講清楚的話
也許他一樣是在這一波出貨的題材上面的話
他可以得到更好的一個表現
這是說不定的
所以其實我們從目前來看的話
你如果是對於他光通性出貨的這個題材
而且是跟靈化因相關的話
其實我們會比較建議說
你可以先從
累積相關的公司
先來做一些關注
因為這兩家公司都已經確定了
要去擴增它MocPD的一個設備
就是說
後面的一個訂單
應該是可以讓投資朋友來做一個期待的
大家如果不敢追賬
也可以輔助於說
他們有回檔的時候
有指紋的時候
再來做介入
因為看來產業的發展跟數字
是都已經繳出來
讓你覺得可以信任的成績單了
這邊非常謝謝古瑜
骨瑜幫我們講了整個CPO
裡面有所謂的細光子
對不對 它是一個光學整合的技術之外
還有靈化因
它是非常重要的關鍵原料
以前不曉得要用這麼多
現在一下子變成要用了
大家如果要生產的話
要立刻擴產 立刻買機台
所以今天就兩檔公司
聯亞跟全新確實已經把機台購入了
來當作產業發展中
一個很重要的訊息
以及我如果我們看到三綠的話
連亞真的是一個直線往上飆升
也可以說明為什麼現在CPU裡面
相關的古王會是連亞
當然他們這個族群目前
霞帶的高成長本益比是比較高的
所以產業趨勢我們知道了
至於買點
也許大家喜歡回購買商場
或者找一個回落的時間點
對他們有信心
這個也是挺重要的
今天非常謝謝三位來賓來到現場
台股漲到這邊
果然往下打了一顆腳
但是這個腳打好後
後面又是一個海闊天空
尤其下載著我們對於陳爺金肥麵
漲價題材的信任
相信之後我們還是有很多的好選擇
也希望今天理財展安秀
最近特別有幫助喔
明天再會了 掰掰